public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
thierry mandon le secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec afp avec radio
classique et avec le journal les échos
trois grandes questions vous seront
posées par jean-francis pécresse marque
réel et mickaël szames s1 comment
éteindre le feu dans les banlieues vous
connaissez bien les banlieues vous êtes
un élu vous même de l'essonne deux
benoît hamon qui a votre soutien naturel
c'est votre mot tarde-t-il selon vous à
entrer dans le costume d'un
présidentiable est ce qu'il peut
vraiment décrocher le leadership de la
gauche je vous le dirai tout à l'heure
enfin 3 est-ce que vous soutenez vous
vraiment la lafa ou même la raréfaction
du travail alors que vous êtes en charge
de l'enseignement supérieur on sait que
les formations supérieures sont la clé
de l'enseignement de demain mais d'abord
une question d'actualité monsieur mandon
à françois fillon ne fait pas l'objet de
nouvelles révélations dans le canard
enchaîné qui sortira demain en revanche
lit-on son porte-parole son unique porte
parole désormais thierry solère est dans
le collimateur du fisc pour avoir omis
de payer une partie des impôts une
enquête préliminaire a été lancée tout à
fait récemment et le canard d'ironiser
la justice lance un missile sol-air sur
la campagne de fillon c'est ça c'est un
nouveau missile judiciaire contre la
campagne du candidat de droite
j'ai pas le privilège de lire le canard
enchaîné avant sa sortie je voulais
résumé la gym dire gg
voilà j'entends donc je découvre je
découvre cela je crois que toute façon
la campagne de françois fillon n'a pas
besoin de missiles supplémentaires elle
est déjà bien bien bien atteinte depuis
quelques semaines à mes attentes
justement par des missiles puisque lui
même le candidat parle d'un harcèlement
judiciaire
non mais
va il ya des faits que d'ailleurs ils ne
contestent pas qu'ils sont graves
même si dit-il ils sont ils sont légaux
et une instruction qu'il appelait de ses
voeux dont il saluait il ya quelques
semaines la rapidité les faits sont
graves d'être vous bah oui oui oui j'ai
pas une entreprise familiale un mandat
parlementaire
à son épouse ses enfants
ces garçons saphir voilà c'est un mandat
parlementaire c'est un mandat de service
du peuple c'est pas un mandat de famille
mais on sait que beaucoup d'élus
parlementaires font travailler leurs
familles accessoirement va alors
peut-être qu'il faudrait effectivement
là on parle d'un emploi présumé fictif
donc à une instru donc j'espère qu'elle
ira plus vite possible selon le voeu
initial de françois fillon lui-même
alors thierry solère qui se dit par
ailleurs aujourd'hui à jour de ses
impôts et qui veut porter plainte comme
pour diffamation s'était déclaré victime
du cabinet noir de l'elysée 1 c'était
lors de la révélation de la plainte de
bercy il ya quelques mois et donc on
reparle d'une machination
c'est un procédé classique de défense de
ceux qui sont attaqués que d'imaginer
que l'elysée n'a rien d'autre à faire de
ses journées que d'aller monter des
coups contre tel ou tel je crois pas que
ce soit le la volonté du programme la
république et je vois d'ailleurs pas
pour quelle raison et s'attaquerait
particulièrement à ce candidat là qui à
ce jour n'est pas en tête dans les
sondages
de moins en moins il était donc il était
avant la révélation tout cela vous le
savez donc je crois qu'il faut laisser à
la presse à son indépendance le droit de
faire ses enquêtes et ses publications
françois fillon prend t-il en otage son
camp ça c'est la vie de jean christophe
cambadélis ce qu'ils auraient dû se
retirer selon vives ou ccc ce que pense
le premier secrétaire de votre parti moi
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup plus que le
fait qu'ils poussent des problèmes à la
droite ce qui viendra chez ces dégâts
sur la république
c'est là
finalement une sorte de putréfaction du
débat politique
aujourd'hui qui fait que tous les grands
enjeux importants pour les français
l'emploi la santé
plus généralement un système de sécurité
sociale l'éducation pas tous ces thèmes
là ne sont plus des battues nulle part
et contre les affaires d'une part et des
campagnes de gérer les 10 règles
autistes en tout cas de nurse ici ce
narcissisme extrême d'autre part avec
des candidatures qui sont sa pas trop ce
qu'elle porte sauf la promotion de soi
le débat politique est vide est absente
cette présentiel et ça c'est très
inquiétant pour la réfection dites vous
pour françois fillon et qui l'a répété
ce matin son retrait qui qui serait une
aubaine pour marine le pen créerait une
crise majeure il a bougé au moment où je
réside d'ailleurs tous les cas marine le
pen elle est complètement dans dans les
mêmes affaires que françois fillon et
c'est même pire que ça puisqu'on est en
train de découvrir coup parlement
européen aucun les employés des
parlementaires front national n'a
travaillé vous avez remarqué qu'elle a
surtout affecté dans les sondages et ça
qu'elle est pas parce que parce que tout
le monde l'aménagement fait la vérité
c'est que c'est c'est pire date est une
industrie c'est une industrie
transformations d'emplois parlementaire
au parlement européen en permanente
partis politiques qui travaillent sur
tout sauf les dossiers européens fallait
première question que vient vous poser
maintenant jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir tier les mendois
question simple direct comment éteindre
le feu dans les banlieues d'abord il
faut sur l'analyse
moi je dirais pas qu'elles le feu dans
les banlieues il ya une les
protestations tue à dire politique
démocratique d'une part de protestation
sur lesquels violente des protestations
sur lesquels se greffent des casseurs
d'autre part dans une partie de la
banlieue qui est la seine saint denis
voilà donc c'est pas encore pas
uniquement pas uniquement via l'outil
des incidents dans vos départements
l'essonne c'est dans une ville
particulière s'est pas encore un
mouvement des mangas c'est moi j'en ai
connu un en 2005 j'étais maire et s'est
pas passé grand-chose à ris orangis
temps l'ouvragé d'art de retour de brice
et beaucoup de problématiques c'était un
mouvement là qu'ils portaient des
revendications particulières là en
espèces y en a qu'une c'est l'attitude
de la police vis à vis des jeunes
donc ce n'est pas un mouvement les
banlieues c'est non mais il faut pas
aller plus vite que la musique et des
revendications de 2005 est notamment
déjà à cette époque là la revendication
d'un récépissé de contrôle d'identité et
puis d'autres revendications qui vous
concerne un petit peu plus directement
d'ailleurs comme le cv est anonymisé oui
mal le sentiment mais vous qui étiez
maire à cette époque que dix ans après
ces revendications elles sont toujours
là et que rien n'a été fait écoutez moi
je vis à ris orangis
donc je vis dans une banlieue je pense
que d'avoir la banlieue
a beaucoup changé il faut pas stéréotypé
les banlieues je pense qu'il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses ces dernières années
premièrement elles ont été massivement
bénéficiaires des emplois tremplins il à
300 milles qui était prioritairement
destiné aux jeunes des quartiers
deuxièmement dans ces quartiers de plus
en plus de jeunes poursuivent des études
après le baccalauréat il ya évidemment
beaucoup d'échec scolaire mais il ya
aussi des parcours de réussite et que
aujourd'hui les revendications ou plutôt
l'état d'esprit dans les banlieues a
beaucoup changé par rapport à ce qu'il
était les années précédentes donc en
en gros en 2005 les habitants demandait
de l'état du service public
il s'agit de la police qu'ils s'agissent
de l'école qu'il s'agisse des systèmes
des socios aujourd'hui demandent un
cocktail beaucoup plus complexe de
présence peut être plus puissante de
l'état je pense notamment au tour de
l'école mais aussi de capacité d'agir de
se développer de créer d'être traités à
égalité dans les entreprises
c'est toute la problématique du cv
anonyme que vous que vous évoquez pour
laquelle je pense qu'on devrait vraiment
faire une une vraie berry table
fermentation expérimentation jaillir à
l' échelle massive
ça c'est des choses qu'on devrait fermer
donc aujourd'hui on est sur des
revendications qui sont pas les
revendications encore donnant pas de
face à un phénomène de man lieu
peut-être que
cela viendra je n'en sais rien en
revanche quel type de politique en dix
ans mettre en place dans ces territoires
là ça c'est un sujet des réserves même
que dans ces quartiers défavorisés
il y à des taux de chômage des jeunes
qui sont au double de la moyenne
nationale en francs et les taux de
chômage sur les moins de 25 ans de 40% à
45% parfois donc il ya eu peut-être un
certain nombre de choses de faites est
ce que d'une certaine manière cet échec
là c'est pas aussi l'échelle du
quinquennat
c'est beaucoup plus que ça c'est
probablement et notamment en termes de
formation des jeunes pas seulement des
cols d'apprentissage les politiques de
quinze ou vingt années dont il faut
mesurer sur les jeunes les moins
qualifiés ils ont échoué
ouais bah et donc je pense qu'il faut
faire des choses très calmement très
froidement avec beaucoup d'énergie pour
la première chose à faire c'est arrêter
de penser les politiques à paris dans
son coin tout seul c'est réunir ceux qui
dans ces territoires là savent comment
il faut faire qu'il s'agisse des mers
qu'il s'agit d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs associatifs et mettre ses
expertises du quotidien en rapport avec
les professionnels de l'emploi et de la
formation qui savent tout mais qui
n'écoute personne parce que c'est très
concrètement je pense à des initiatives
à toulouse comme il y en a qui a été
monté par une association de terrain qui
a réussi à imposer à une séminaire de
travail à l'équipe du pôle emploi aux
associations dead à l'emploi des jeunes
à la municipalité et séminaires qui a
été très féconds mois disons les choses
autrement il faut repenser les
politiques publiques en direction de ses
quartiers à partir des savoirs citoyens
ou associatifs qui existe et non pas à
partir d'un séminaire d'énarques
parisiens qui ont une représentation de
la de la banlieue et donc de ce qu'il
faut y faire qui n'est pas de talent
aurait offert à la réalité entre les
jeunes et la police
dans ces cités est ce qu'il ya selon
vous une stigmatisation
ouais ou même d'éviter des violences
pense que
on avait il ya une certaine époque ce
qu'on appelait la police de proximité
donc d'ailleurs à l'ancien président
république s'était beaucoup moqué
considérant que cette police finalement
fait de l'animation sociale miss
sportive ou nicolas sarkozy mais elle a
été recréée poteau non pas c'est juste
une erreur
moi je crois que la relation directe
entre les policiers et les jeunes de ces
quartiers est indispensable surtout que
fait les jeunes et la population de ces
quartiers parce qu'encore une fois la
quasi totalité de la population de ces
quartiers ne pose pas de difficulté
c'est pas c'est pas les problèmes
massifs c'est de la haute couture sur
quelques jeunes qui pour le coup sont
soit délinquants soient ensemble très
graves difficultés
mais pour le reste c'est du droit commun
d'où vient le problème est ce que c'est
la formation des jeunes policiers
maintenant qui laisse à désirer
peut-être est-ce qu'ils sont ou besson
moins aguerris à cette forme de chalets
pas dire de guérilla urbaine des deux
mais de collaboration terry lors qu'est
ce qui est parfois très vives c'est
qu'ils étaient qui est extrêmement
violente et dans l'affirmation peut-être
parce qu'on l'a beaucoup dit il d'une
virilité policière c'est très mise en
cause ça c'est juste même si comme vous
le savez la police c'est quand même
beaucoup féminisée ces dernières ces
dernières années de plus en plus de
fonctionnaires femmes dans le molise
mais vous avez raison il ya sur ces
interpellations s'est pas souvent des
femmes qui n'en contact très
probablement bel acteur il ya très
probablement une responsabilité à tous
quelque chose à réfléchir en termes de
formation concrète et de terrain des
policiers et peut-être aussi en termes
de prod2 d'encadrement de proximité de
deh équipe mais il ya aussi des choses
qui tiennent un discours général
le discours général qui est véhiculée
sur les banlieues dans le débat public
c'est quoi c'est laborieux c'est un
repère de délinquants ou de ou de jean
quasiment prêt terroristes il ya un
climat qui tend les choses de dieu qui
est deux qui vous incriminez qu'il est
un discours général mais les médias mais
comme quand on parle de banlieue je vous
dis banlieue si demain n'importe qui
chante i tried ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le design thinking
voilà je vous pose la question si je
vous dis banlieues dites moi 3 auquel
vous allez penser que vous n'avez pas me
dire créativité
parcours de réussite vous allez me dire
peur insécurité chômage violence voilà
et ce discours là pour voir comment la
fédération quand même à une grande part
de vérité absolument pas je suis
absolument je vis en valeur une fois je
viens à ris orangis absolument pas c'est
totalement faux il ya des difficultés
mais il ya énormément de 2,2 de
créativité bien sûr mais vous avez
raison il faut mettre en avant
effectivement les exemples de réussite
et ils sont nombreux dans les banlieues
et les exemples d'intégration merci mais
j'en passe deuxième partie de l'épreuve
de vérité c'est avec marc ruelle de la
fp que nous accueillons maintenant
l'épreuve des victimes et qui marque
bon sang mais votre question à thierry
mentor vachement bon on parlait en début
d'émission de votre soutien à benoît
hamon le soutien naturel
le candidat socialiste était dans une
phase tactique compliqué il et il essaie
de convaincre
yannick jadot et jean luc mélenchon de
de se retirer et ce qui perd trop de
temps est ce qui s qui perd du temps
dans sa campagne et ce qu'ils perdent du
temps pour rentrer dans le costume de
présidentiable
je ne sais pas s'il perd du temps ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il faut s'y mettre
faut y aller il faut y aller il a mis le
doigt dans la campagne primaire sur des
sujets essentiels qui méritent sûrement
d'être travaillée d'ailleurs je crois
que c'est en train de se faire sur la
question du revenu de base revenu
universel tous les débats autour de 2,2
ce sujet là des minima sociaux améliorée
sur la question de l'avenir du travail
donc non il faut y aller il faut
remettre ces débats c'est ça dont il
faut parler aux français les français
ils veulent qu'on leur parle emploi
santé c'est qu'une sécurité protection
sociale écoles ils veulent pas qu'on
leur parle de jean luc mélenchon de
yannick jadot ou d'emmanuel mâcon voilà
est donc sain campagne et je pense que
c'est ça qui travaille elle doit
orienter là dessus j'observe points
positifs en contrepoint de ce que je
veux dire qu'il est le premier homme
politique à ma connaissance à se
présenter à une présidentielle en
demandant à des chercheurs à des gens
qui viennent de la recherche publique à
des gens qui ont des connaissances de
l'aider à bonifier son programme
et ça c'est vrai que ça demande un petit
peu de temps a été désigné avec un jour
qu'il fallait quinze jours pour faire ce
travail là c'est tout à fait normal
imagine que dans les jours ou les
semaines qui viennent il va sortir cet
été votre position thomas piketty en
fait qui perd un peu de temps mais je
pense qu'il s'est passé quand même pas
le plus mauvais des experts des mois que
thomas piketty travail sur le revenu de
base
moi ça me réjouis et je suis persuadé
que sans trahir les engagements de nos
amont on aura des propositions de mise
en oeuvre que dominique méda spécialiste
du travail et des souffrances au travail
travaillent sur ces questions là qu'ils
sont majeurs pour les français c'est
plutôt bien et qu'un candidat prennent
le temps alors qu'il n'y en a pas alors
qu'il n'a pas de demander à ces
équipes-là d'essayer de bonifier ses
propositions c'est une belle démarche
qui mérite d'être salué vous parlez le
cône de la putréfaction du débat
démocratique avait visé les affaires de
françois fillon vous avez parlé d'un
candidat narcissiquement et celle de
était manager visé aussi affaire de mari
et de marine le pen parce qu'il faut
quand même pas les oublier là on a quand
même une casserole en pagaille est ce
que cette putréfaction qu'on peut un peu
constaté ces derniers jours elle ne
concerne pas aussi benoît hamon veut
dire voilà il avait cet espace de porter
ces idées dont vous parliez et puis
voilà il perd ce temps cette fenêtre
c'est très net prenantes parce que
encore une fois que après un travail
d'une désignation entre guy m'a surprise
aux primaires je sais pas si beaucoup
avaient prévu la déviation de noirmont
que il fasse travailler des équipes
qu'il a encore le temps même mais c'est
vrai que le temps là c'était pas les
candidats rire et moi je n'ai pas de
candidat fait que moi j'étais j'ai
beaucoup souffert à la primaire ne sais
pas je sais que je ne savais pas quoi
faire
une primeur pourquoi parce que je ne je
n'avais pas de candidat qui représentait
la sensibilité de gauche à l'appui donc
ce n'était pas votre candidat est et
d'une part et que deuxièmement j'ai
refusé la logique binaire dans laquelle
on a essayé nous enfermer dans cette
primaire qui était si vous êtes pour le
bilan vous dites c'était génial ce qu'on
a fait les français n'ont rien compris
c'est quand même incroyable leur
expliquer où vous étiez contre le bilan
il y avait rien à prendre un but or je
pense que le créneau de la gauche
la stratégie pour que la gauche fasse le
meilleur score possible à la primaire à
la présidentielle c'est celle qui part
d'un certain nombre d'éléments du bilan
qu'il faut assumer revendiqué comme tel
à tous et en même temps considère on est
rentré dans une nouvelle période
politique et que les réponses de
prolongation du quinquennat pour les
cinq ans qui viennent ça marche pas
cadets
changement de braquet à faire sur un
certain nombre de sujets voilà c'est ça
que doit faire benoît hamon trouver
prendre appui sur un certain nombre de
choix qui ont été faits dans le premier
quinquennat par tous parce qu'il portait
les critiques tout à fait recevable mais
prendre appui là dessus mais en même
temps voir comment on change de braquet
sur les questions centrales comme le
travail la protection sociale par
exemple la démocratie des institutions
si on veut d'autres exemples et tendre
la main à jean luc mélenchon ça sert à
quelque chose aujourd'hui
non il faut arrêter quoi vous laisser
tomber non mais s'il en est qui monte
des bonnes intentions pas s'il s'agit là
présente enfin il n'y a rien à attendre
jean-luc mélenchon est parti en croisade
autour de lui-même
c'est ça l'histoire certaine manière il
s'est autoproclamé sauveur du pays
et pourquoi voulez-vous que celui qui
fait cette démarche là d'isaba benoîte a
été désigné par deux millions de
personnes bon bah je te laisse te laisse
la place donc à l'évidence en tout cas
ici premier tout il restera quand il a
donc c'est que de l'affichage
probablement pas de discuter on est en
démocratie démocratie c'est pas du
conflit contre tout le monde ça peut
être des discussions mais il n'y a pas à
attendre de restructuration de l'offre à
gauche
c'est dommage mais c'est comme ça ici
premier tour de la présidentielle quand
vous regardez plutôt plus vers le sens
vers la droite vers emmanuel macron
l'autre candidat qui se revendique
finalement 2 qui pourrait se revendiquer
comme héritier de ce quinquennat en tout
cas les farines qui pourrait épouser
raison de mettre un conditionnel parce
qu'il ne fait pas
pas très fort et c'est pas lui
l'héritier plus légitime du quinquennat
hollande que benoît hamon finalement
belle trop la traîne à rien non plus
d'autres comme moi je n'ai pas le
sentiment que emmanuel macron dans sa
campagne revendique défendre le bilan
est fait applaudir par l'est les troupes
en liesse qui réunit dans les assemblées
j'ai le sentiment qu'il faut moins
pudique discret surtout sa partie ces
cinq années faire 4-1 émis d'actions ou
soit auprès du présent soit ce
gouvernement
le discours que porte emmanuel macron
sur son programme quand il dit
finalement le programme n'est pas le
coeur d'une campagne électorale ça vous
choque
ça vous inquiète qu'un politicien qui
n'est pas un extrémiste porte ce genre
de l'escaut mais sais tu de la
difficulté de là il n'a pas totalement
tort la difficulté des mâles macron
c'est quoi c'est qu'il peut dire ce
qu'il veut faire les propositions
il veut d'ailleurs il en a fait quand
même un certain nombre et il ne manquera
toujours la cohérence pour les français
la lisibilité simple de ces propositions
il veut s'extraire du débat droite
gauche il en paye le prix
il est illisible le restaurant où il est
il est insaisissable mais oui parce que
la gauche la droite on peut et on peut
vous on peut vouloir gauche plus moderne
on peut vous là une droite plus de plus
rythmé mais sa structure l'inconscient
collectif donc illégal et c'est pas une
invention cetc séculaire ça fait des
siècles que la vie politique française
s'ordonne autour de ça et mon sentiment
c'est que lui en refusant ce clivage l'
iran illisible ce qu'il propose donc il
est voué à l'échec
en tout cas lui même considère que si
jamais vous votre jugement
moi mon jugement c'est qu'on a une
époque de repos lisation pas seulement
française internationale
je pense que là on parle des manuels mac
dont je vis à vis mais j'essaie de vous
donner les raisons pour lesquelles je
pense que s'extraire de ce de cette
bipolarité là c'est aujourd'hui une
erreur je pense que toutes les vies
politiques se recompose on l'a vu en
angleterre on l'a vu aux états unis on
l'a vue d'une certaine manière en
espagne en voit partout autour d'une
droite plus dur et d'une gauche plus
faire en cas de nul part et lui il est
en dehors de ça il peut bien proposer ce
qu'il veut je pense que il ne sera pas
saisissable parce qu'il refuse cette
réalité là de la recomposition des
scènes politiques enfin on n'a pas parlé
de marine le pen ou 10 et à l'heure
qu'il y avait une forme de clémence
vis-à-vis de la candidate frontiste est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez actes et
qu'elle serait au second tour est ce que
c'est un paramètre qui ne changera plus
par mois est ce que je
j'observe une forme de résignation en
tout cas de la société vis-à-vis de
marine le pen elle peut aller n'importe
où n'importe quel plateau de télévision
raconter n'importe quoi sans que
personne ne la reprenne
je vais donner deux exemples récents
sans nommer ceux qui sont concernés mais
enfin tout le monde comprendra elle va
dans une émission explique qu'à 7
millions de chômeurs en france
moi je suis plutôt appuyé sur les
sciences sociales ou que je regarde ça
de presse je ne sais pas d'où sort cette
ati ci qu'elle est complètement
fantaisistes et mensongères elle dit que
nous non pas du tout il ya rien aucun
problème au parlement européen
tous les emplois fictifs pour lui
reproche c'est un mauvais procès de
l'europe contre un joueur qui a pas un
qui a bossé pour le front national qui
s'est occupé de quelques dossiers
européens que ce soit donc là bien
l'argent de l'europe qui a été détourné
pour faire fonctionner un parti
politique français que personne ne lui
dit rien et je trouve que dans cette
espèce de capacités qu'elle a à dire
n'importe quoi sans que personne ne lui
rappelle un certain nombre de principes
il ya un indicateur de résignation 10
disons disons de les journées de la
société voilà et de journal de la
société en général et ça c'est pas
possible
moi je sais aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles je m'engage dans cette
campagne et je soutiens le noirmont je
pense qu'il faut mener le combat de fond
à la fois vis-à-vis de manuels de marine
le pen mais aussi et surtout sur
l'affirmation d'un certain nombre de
vérités de réalité dans la vie publique
on peut pas dire n'importe quoi car
quand on dit n'importe quoi ça donne
donald trump
hier ça peut donner marine le pen de
demain ici et elle peut gagner demain
oui vous faites partie de ceux qui
considèrent qu'elle peut gagner et nous
verrons si on renonce et si elle renonce
c'est sûr mais celui-ci par avance on
renonce au combat dans les politiques ce
qui l'y attend
merci marc troisième partie d'épreuve
vérité maintenant avec michaël szames s
de public sénat qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir michael mont-saint-michel vont
soit retirée bonsoir est ce que vous
croyez à la fin du travail
non non non non je crois pas non je
crois pas du tout à ça mais j'observe
qu'il ya des travaux tout à fait
important qu'ils sont en train de faire
est d'être fait dans le monde entier
ceux que ça intéresse peuvent les
trouver dans un publication combien
faire au ministère qui s'appelle le
livre blanc de la recherche et
l'enseignement supérieur page 34
vous avez l'état des débats dans le
monde entier sur cette réflexion que va
devenir le travail dans les années
qu'est ce que vous croyez que benoît
hamon l'a lu benoît hamon s'intéresse
beaucoup à la recherche et il a eu le
livre blanc donc je pense que il est un
il est il y ça et qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'est ce que le seul point d'accord
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils regardent et
transformation très profonde
premièrement ça c'est sûr dans les
années qui viennent à une vitesse
accélérée
deuxièmement il ya des emplois qui vont
disparaître ce qui demande peu de
qualifications probablement d'autres
font émerger mais alors après sur les
quantification plus qui disparaissent
moi qui disparaissent la personne ne
sait où ce que dit benoît hamon c'est
qu'on ne travaillera plus de la même
façon
vous qui êtes avec les enseignants qui
est avec les chercheurs avec des
étudiants est-ce que aussi pour qu on ne
travaillera plus même façon dans les
années qui viennent
alors oui il le croit benoît hamon il a
un des tabous écrit dans le benoît moins
dorée féroé et le crois oui le crois
mais je crois qu'il a un diagnostic pour
le coup très intelligent on peut être en
désaccord mais en tout cas qui est très
fin sur la question du travail parce
qu'il a une vision quantitative il dit
en gros il y en aura moins bon le
travail est là millions qualitative
aussi il dit aujourd'hui le travail
c'est une souffrance est ce qu a inventé
une société où le travail des fournées
n'est plus un accomplissement est ce que
c'est pour vous une révolution
nécessaire
maintenant il faut qu'ils doivent
redevenir un accomplissement blessure
ben écoutez si on regarde les choses là
aussi très simplement il ya deux
générations et 20% de qualifier en
france aujourd'hui on a 45%
mais la génération prochaine ce sera
plus de 50% de qualifier au niveau de
l'enseignement supérieur
vous pouvez pas traiter ces gens comme
si c'était des des gens qu'elle ait pas
de l'intelligence de la créativité en
leur disant c'est comme ça fait ce que
vous avez à faire
prenez ce petit salaire parce que vous
comprenez si on vous donne un salaire un
peu plus élevé les chinois ne sais pas
quels pays vont nous hanter nos brousses
si c'est ça le projet pour la france
c'est un projet qui est d'ailleurs dans
le projet mais aussi la réduction du
temps de travail
ça va dans le sens de l'histoire saléen
du sens en mettant de travail en terme
oui historiquement on est absolument
jusqu'à maintenant et que jusqu'à
maintenant ce qui est mieux que le le le
travail c'est toujours la durée du
travail c'est toujours réduits moi je
crois qu'ils vont faire et 300 go
l'augmenter oui enfin on veut augmenter
on veut supprimer les postes de
fonctionnaires donc on supprime 500
mille fonctionnaires on augmente la
durée du travail
il vaut mieux pas de chômeurs parce que
s'il ya mon poste de fonctionnaire et si
ceux qui travaillent travaillent plus
longtemps je sais pas comment vous
trouver un travail
je vous propose d'écouter pierre gattaz
1 qui estime qu'il peut y avoir un
avenir radieux en france avec une
croissance forte 2% et qui peut même y
avoir un retour au plein emploi donc il
a une vision optimiste mais en revanche
il est très pessimiste quand ils voient
justement le programme économique de
votre candidat benoît hamon sur
différents thèmes et notamment sur celui
de la raréfaction du travail en écoute
pierre gattaz qui était d'autres invités
ici même et benoît hamon est beaucoup
plus sûre ya plus de travail les robots
donc il veut taxer fnac c'est avant tout
accès non il n'ya pas que ça il va
enlever les quarantenaires du pas de
responsabilité allons-y et puis je sais
pas quand il va faire donc c'est une
économie totalement administrées
idéalement pour lui je croise en
entreprise ce sera encore mieux
donc si vous voulez là je suis très
angoissé et enfin on voit ces deux sens
sur le plan irréalisme de du programme
qui n'existe pas sur le plan économique
c'est juste des dépenses et plus et
c'est de taxer encore plus tout ce qu'on
peut coiffer irréaliste c'est un peu
caricatural
il explique dans un premier temps que
cette horrible programme économique de
benoît hamon et dans un deuxième temps
qui ne connaît pas le programme
économique
benoît mans je pense que la réalité
c'est dans les thèmes de campagne et
qu'il faut maintenant mettre sur la
table pour benoît hamon la question de
la stratégie économique y est une
question majeure s'est pas tu rêves
il aime l'entreprise bah oui d'abord il
a été ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire c'est de l'économie
c'est une partie importante du pays
c'est pas celui que toute l'économie je
veux dire certes vous avez dit mais s'il
va lui voir présenter aux médias moi je
moi je pense qu'il manque un projet pour
l'aller l'économie et l'entreprise dans
le projet de drama et je pense qu'il est
en train d'y travailler et qu'un certain
nombre de personnes
taxer les robots vous ok j'en fais pour
sable des chercheurs attendus taxer les
robots
j'en fais pas l'alpha et l'oméga d'un
projet m'éloigner vous êtes contre même
si c'est maintenant évident mais pour
qu'elle vous êtes contre non pourquoi
pourquoi je suis pas contre x mais
pourquoi après tout les machines là dans
l'est dans les supermarchés à lesquels
vous avez maintenant avec votre produit
faire adultes d'aller voir une caissière
pourquoi elle n'aura pas une petite
taxation c'est parce qu est très bon
dans sailor aussi des bilans ou villars
aussi pour votre portefeuille
de quoi est ce que vous êtes vous le
plus fier c'est je crois avoir réussi à
convaincre en tout cas participer à coin
qu'il fallait remettre de l'argent un
système de recherche et du nouveau est
battu vous avez obtenus grâce notamment
à des prix nobel j'ai obtenu grâce au
prix nobel qu'on était prêt face à
françois hollande il m'a fallu
convaincre de secouer tout ça pour que
ce qui arbitre les finances publiques et
là c'est pas françois hollande à bercy
comprennent qu'il faut mettre de
l'argent dans le livre blanc de la
recherche d'enseignement supérieur pour
les années qui viennent
j'ai fait des propositions très précises
de réinvestissement comparé à ce que
font les autres pays au monde en ce
moment et j'ai même une conviction
confondent c'est que la france a une
carte extraordinaire à jouer en
angleterre aujourd'hui le mot existe et
annie de chercheurs aux états unis trump
fait peur à tous les campus
universitaires
si la france donne un signal fort dans
la présentielle à gauche ou à droite
importe qu'elle est prête à réinvestir
un peu sur ces sujets là elle va tirer
les meilleures idées des chercheurs
venus en france bien sûr mais je dis oui
enfin je le redis je dis d'abord au
budgétaire mettez un peu de sous pour
qu'on puisse les accueillir
car il faut les accueillir quitter le
gouvernement dans trois mois à peu près
n'ai pas l'intention de vous représenter
aux élections législatives n'ont fait
quoi moi je veux produire des idées
diffuser ses idées ses terres que je
pense qu un double problème du port doit
pas tout seul
je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
adaptation intellectuelle et culturelle
affaires de pour entrer dans le monde
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui et elle qui
sera dans les années qui viennent et on
les esprits ne sont pas prêts ça si je
peux donner quelques effets et puis
faire circuler ses idées dans ta
question l'outil de diffusion est très
importante merci à vous merci michael
merci à tous à la semaine prochaine